翻訳: Midori Imai
校正: Hiroko Kawano
私は 富山県で
来年100周年を迎える和菓子屋の
４代目をしています
業界で重鎮と言われるような師匠について
伝統的な和菓子について学ばせて頂きました
今でも尊敬している師匠です
早速なんですけれども
スライドが出てますけれども
お菓子を１つ 作ってみたいと思います
その場で作るというのは
ちょっとなんかハードルが高いですけれども
やらせて頂きます
非常に小さい 手の中で作る品を
やっておりますので
なかなか難しい所も
あるかと思うんですけれども
今はですね
自分の とても大事なデザインを作っています
見えますでしょうか？
これは 招き猫です
（拍手）
こういうデモンストレーションの
仕事をさせて頂くと
よく「こういう和菓子職人になるには
何年ぐらいかかるんですか」と尋ねられます
ものづくりをされたり
表現をするようなお仕事をされている方は
よくされる質問ではないかと
思うんですけれども
こういう形を綺麗に整えるだけであれば
器用な方でしたら ２〜３年もあれば
ある程度のところまではいけると思います
ただ その質問に対して私は
「10年かかります」という風にお答えします
その理由の大きなひとつは
和菓子を作る材料は
豆であったり 米 芋
全て農作物が中心となっています
農作物はその年の作柄によって
豊作もあれば不作もあります
非常に良い状態のものが入る場合と
あまり良くない状態のものが入る年と
さらにその作物が採れてから
１ヶ月 ３ヶ月 半年と経っていくと
状態はどんどん変わっていきます
そういうものに対して
毎年チャレンジをして
より良いものを作ろうとして 挑んでいく
１年で１回 10年やって
やっと10回それをすることができます
ですので 形を整えるだけが
こういう和菓子の技術ではなくて
その 農作物と向き合えるだけの
技術を手に入れるためには10年
そんな風に考えています
近年はですね
結構こういうお菓子の実演を
評価して頂いて
いろんなイベントの会場で
実演させて頂くんですけれども
ある時 台湾に呼んで頂いて
皆さんの前で
日本の伝統的な季節の桜ですとか
桔梗 菊 色々なお花を作ってみました
でも 気候風土も違いますし
咲くお花も全然違うので
なにかこう「 日本の人が
器用なことをしてるなあ」 ぐらいの
まあ 盛り上がってなかったんですね
それが非常に僕としては残念で
日本の和菓子の面白さを
伝えようと思ってきたはずが
盛り上がっていない
通訳の方に
「台湾の方は 日本のもので
何がお好きなんでしょう？」とお尋ねした時に
コレクターがいるぐらい
招き猫が好きだという風に伺いました
それで 急遽 現場で考えて作ったのが
この招き猫であります
これを作り始めてからは
もう本当に大げさじゃなく
私のブースの前が 黒山の人だかりに
なるぐらい盛り上がりまして
すごく その時は良かったなあと
思ってたんですけども
帰りの便の中で
僕は伝統を守れるような職人に
なりたいと思っていたので
日本ではこういう変わったものは
作るまいと心に決めて帰国しました
その後も 色々な会場で
イベントをさせて頂いて
いろんなお客様の前で
お菓子を作りました
ある時 めぐりが悪かったのか
親御さんの 若いお母さんとお子さん
そういう組み合わせの方が何回か来られて
お子さんは 僕が作ってるお菓子を見て
「お花きれい 食べたい」って
言ってくださるんですけれども
親御さんの方は「これはお茶のお菓子だから
あなたの食べるものじゃないわ」 と言って
手を引いて帰って行ったんです
そういうことがその日は
なぜか４回ぐらい重なって
また夕方に同じような場面になりまして
ちょっといたずら心でというか
少し悔しさもあったんですけれども
この招き猫をはじめて作ってみたんです
そうするとお子さんは「あ 猫 猫！」と
すごい盛り上がって お母さんも
和菓子屋の前で「猫 猫」と言ってるから
気になって見てくれて「ああ かわいい」と
で ２人で猫とお花のお菓子を
買って帰っていきました
買って頂けたことが嬉しいというよりも
和菓子　—
和菓子の中でも
比較的とっつきにくいタイプの
お茶席菓子として皆さん認知されている
上生菓子の世界に
その親子の おふたりが入ってきてくれた
そのことがとても嬉しかったです
そういう経験をして思ったのは
なにかその 自分が伝統を守りたいと
そんな風に思って
そういう新しいことに挑まないというのは
何か違うんじゃないか
それって何か僕の勝手な
独りよがりなんじゃないかなあ
という風に思い始めてからは
お客様のリクエストに即興でお答えして
猫だとか ハリネズミとか 犬とか
そういう変わったデザインを作れば
例えば 歌の歌詞とか 映画の場面とか
そういったオーダーを頂いて
お作りするような
もちろん こういう形だけではなくて
味であったりとか
例えばお酒と合わせる
そういうことにも
挑戦させて頂くようになりました
皆さん ご存知だと思うんですけれども
桜餅 ありますよね
春の定番の伝統的な
お菓子ですけれども
あれが 出た時というか
発売された当時
それは 言葉は悪いんですけれども
「狂気のお菓子」というか
「クレイジーなお菓子」に
見えたんじゃないかなあという
想像をしてしまうんですけれども
桜の葉を摘んで 塩漬けにして
翌年花の咲く前に 餅に巻いて
「桜餅です」
結構 相当な大きい
チャレンジだと思うんです
多分 発売された当初
初日はですね
評価してくれる人もいるのかも
しれないですけれども
かなり 批判を浴びたんじゃないか
という風な気がするんです
だけれども そういうチャレンジによって
桜餅というお菓子が生まれて
僕たちが春になると桜餅を作って
商売をさせて頂く
そう考えた時に 自分は伝統を守りたい
と言う風に思っていましたけれども
それはすごい おこがましいというか
なんかこう 伝統に僕らは守られていて
その中で 色々なチャレンジを
しているんじゃないかという風に
イメージするようになりました
先人が すごいチャレンジをして
うまくいったもの いかなかったもの
それこそ 血と汗と涙を流して
そういったものが
大きな川のように流れていく
そういう伝統というものが
そういう風なイメージに見えてからは
それに守られながら 師匠から教わった
伝統的な和菓子づくりっていうものを
自分のベースにして それに守られながら
その川に向かってどんどん挑んでいって
遊んで 挑みかかっていくような
そういう風なことをしていかないと
自分の要素なんて 伝統の中に
一滴も残らないんじゃないかなって
いう風に考えるようになりました
そう考えてからは
本当に気持ちが楽になって
色々な挑戦に 躊躇せずに
挑んでいけるように なりました
ぼくたちみたいな 伝統的な仕事と
言われているタイプの仕事ですけれども
チャレンジすることに躊躇する必要は
なかったんだと思います
自由に遊べるようになるための修行を
していたんじゃないかなあ というくらい
自分の中で 考えが変わりまして
今でもいろいろなお菓子を作っています
自分の桜餅が生まれる瞬間を楽しみにして
これからも お菓子作りを
挑んでやっていきたいと思います
ありがとうございます
（拍手）